there's no one else in the universe can
do what we're doing
[Applause]
[Music]
classic who review time and yes I am
gonna keep my monthly classic Doctor Who
as well as my monthly Big Finish on the
normal Sunday slot but the Sundays that
aren't for these may or may not end up
being Doctor Who while the new series is
running because that just might be too
much but in any case yes I didn't want
to stop catching up on classic stuff and
getting my reviews out on them and this
time I decided to get a second doctor
story that you know would actually be
good so I you know I gave the options to
my patreon they voted on some second
doctor stories and what they selected
was tomb of the Cybermen at present I
can safely say my favorite second doctor
story that I've seen as with most of the
doctors there's a fair chunk of their
stuff I still haven't gotten through
poking most of the doctors I've seen if
not reviewed what is generally
considered to be the best of their stuff
so tomb of the Cybermen where do we
begin with this well first of all the
Isle of a second doctor I the second
doctor and Jamie I'm not certain it's my
favorite doctor companion pairing but
it's right up there it's it's gonna be
it's like a tough competition between a
couple indeed that's definitely
neck-and-neck with with some of the
other best pairings so I love that and I
actually quite like Victoria who so far
as I can tell did not stick around for a
very long time which is a bit of a shame
because she has in this story for lack
of a better term she has a spunk to her
that I really like she is rather
frequently across the story sort of oh
no you know the women have to stay
behind while the men go ahead I'll kind
of come back to those kinds of elements
of this story but you can see her
annoyance at that and maybe I'm reading
too much into it but knowing that she
comes from a time period actually what
was before I believe she came from the
1800s and somebody will correct me if
I'm wrong on that but she seemed really
frustrated that women's positions in the
future in space
you know on this archaeological
expedition didn't seem to have gotten
any better she seems really frustrated
by that which is good because I am
frustrated for her so for her to share
that I not just be accepting of it in
dear sir to me a fair bit I'm so I mean
that's your that's your you know your
core characters doctor and the two
companions of the time so what's the
plot on this the plot is that you know
taking Victoria on her first offworld
adventure because this is the second
story she appears and the first one evil
of the Daleks is unfortunately one of
the lost adventures there might be audio
of it I need to look into that but so
she is just coming off the Telex dealing
with them they killed her father so she
they're they're coming off that and they
land on the planet tellus which well
there's a there's an archaeological dig
going on here and it's one that's been
you know kind of rushed it's a little
ill-prepared there's you know there's
the archaeologist heading it but there's
also the guy funding it who seems very
insistent and the whole thing has a it
has the vibe of like really pushing fur
for people like oh no go and uncover
that pyramid no no I'll stay back here
don't worry about the Mummy's curse just
go go go go go yeah it's not quite that
detachment has that that feel to it in
terms of the vibe of the expedition as a
whole and what they have found are the
titular tombs of the Cybermen it is a
basically a station where Cybermen have
set up and they have frozen themselves
if chronologically frozen themselves cry
lodging cryogenically frozen themselves
and we now have basically a a trapped
with Cybermen story and there's so much
I love about this story first of all
let's talk about the Cybermen themselves
this was the this I think saw their
first major redesign they appeared on
the moon base
I think which was the second doctor
story I think in that one they still had
the like sock mask thing going on I
should have looked that up but you know
this has sort of the trapdoor mouth and
I think the most electronic sounding
voice that the Cybermen ever had which
it on a first viewing can make it
sometimes difficult to understand what
they're saying but at the same time is
really effective in getting it that
inhuman quality to their voice and the
doctor does you give that reminder early
on these are not robots there are people
or at least parts of people inside these
things so to know that have that
reiterated early on and then have the
doctor you know by having the doctor
point out and then hearing this
incredibly inhuman voice is really cool
it also I believe it's our first
introduction to the idea of a cyber
controller because before we had just
seen the Cybermen like as a collective I
kind of a bit like the Borg and
obviously predating them severely and
here we have the introduction of one
that looks a little bit different and is
in charge and that's the cyber control
who's got a little bit bigger of a dome
and look it's sort of decorated to look
like there might be like a larger brain
actually encased in there then is
standard for the Cybermen and the it's
funny I I was watching this and there's
a refrain there's something that they
keep saying that I think absolutely
epitomizes what is scary about the
Cybermen and it shows how badly Russell
T Davies missed the mark with his cyber
smen reinvention of them because you
know what was their refrain in that from
series to delete delete delete they
might as well be saying exterminate you
know it's just their equivalent of that
but here the refrain that we keep
hearing is we will survive and that cuts
to the core of why these things are
scary because they are the epitome of
survival at all costs all cost to
external damage and all cost
self it doesn't all that matters is that
you survived that this race survives
that is their only goal and to survive
and to continue to exist and to expand
out if they're able to by making others
like like they themselves are but just
the refrain of that we will survive and
there's there's a there's a hot like
level of insistence on it even through
the electronic monotone like you really
get a sense this is the core of what
these things are and it's what makes
them scary now it does to a certain
extent you know suffer from the
cheesiness of the era so you know I say
scary I mean conceptually scary you look
at them and it's very obviously people
in shiny suits doing this but even
taking that into account there's
actually some really impressive
production design going on here we first
of all we get a fair number of Cybermen
so you don't feel the limitations like
oh there's only like three and they're
shooting it to make it look like this
one no there's a decent number of them
but the tombs themselves is it's
actually a pretty dang impressive set
you know it's tall and neat and they are
contained within these things and they
sort of break through this cellophane
which I believe started the tradition of
the Cybermen kind of breaking through
stuff as their big entrance something
that would be a little bit recurring as
the as the show would go on but it's
it's a Daniel pressive set not just the
tombs themselves but the entire sort of
catacombs the yeah all of the this place
that they found it looks pretty dang
good especially for the time you know I
really do find that the black and white
you paint it over a lot of sins I I do
honestly think that the show didn't
start looking cheap until it went to
color because color is a lot less
forgiving it's a lot easier to fake
stuff when you you don't have to worry
about color matching or you know the
color giving away the the nature of the
the texture or whatever else so it it
ends up looking pretty dang impressive
now there's sort of more than one
villain going on here as well because we
have the Cybermen but we also have I
meant
him already the guy who funded the
expedition a guy named Eric
klieg who is from the Society of
logicians basically he is a guy who is
just smart enough to cause a lot of
problems but does not realize that he's
not nearly as smart as he thinks he is
which makes him additionally dangerous
because he thinks that he can control
the Cybermen he thinks he can negotiate
with them he has a very inflated view of
himself of his world view of what he
could do if he were in charge but he's
just is a he's just a petty little man
he's actually kind of surprisingly well
realized as a villain because he it and
I'm gonna put that down to the
performance and sort of working in
conjunction with him is as a woman I
called kaftan who has a what I can only
call a manservant named
Toberman now I can't talk about these
three without sort of bringing up one of
what I consider to be two notable issues
with the story
this one is an issue with the passage of
time they basically did something that
was acceptable at the time and is really
kind of cringy now the other thing I
think was actually a flaw of the story
at the time but I'll come back to that
and that is that basically this story
kinda comes off as a bit racist
if I'm being blunt Toberman himself is
the biggest issue because it's Toberman
his black you know very very dark skin
and he he is a you know very stuttered
basic speech super strong but not shown
to be particularly intelligent servant
he does what he's told he's and that you
know that's it that's all he does and as
far as the other two are concerned I did
look into there there were actual
national heritage the guy who plays
klieg I believe was
but he had sort of that olive covered
colored skin and he was frequently cast
you know in that era as characters of a
more Middle Eastern Bennett which seems
to be the accent he's going for here and
then caftan I actually couldn't find out
a lot about that actress she does she
appears to more or less retired in the
70s even though she's still around but
the image I founded of her or more
recently she's quite white and she looks
like she's been browned up and even if
she hasn't even if that's somehow a
quirk of the shooting that that wasn't
actually done she's still sporting a non
British accent and basically all three
human villains are very decidedly not
angle not anglo-saxon not white not
British and yeah that's kind of
problematic because there aren't any
characters of color that aren't part of
the bad guys and again as I said that's
that's unfortunate I'm not gonna go so
far as to say that it was deliberately
racist or that it was a yo creates and
intended subtext but it does it is a
problem they probably didn't think too
much about it you know with that casting
with those choices but yeah it's it's a
little bit tough to watch now that said
the performance is for what the
characters are are solid klieg
especially I think gives a quite a quite
a good performance quite an engaging one
especially for someone who easily could
have been you know just the villain
you're like okay will somebody kill this
guy already I actually quite enjoyed his
time on screen not that I like liked him
of the character not supposed to like
him but I enjoyed his presence and what
it did for the story now to be fair not
every character who isn't this three is
strictly speaking British because we
have we have the we have the crew of the
rocket and I actually kind of love this
I found this adorable who are Americans
exceptions it's that weird accent that
you get from British people trying to
sound as American as possible so you get
well gosh I'll tell you somebody went
and just messed up the rocket I can't
hand
with you people around and the women
need to stay behind and it's it's funny
like it's what I just I find that
inherently funny I'm not sure it's
supposed to be but I do yeah I get humor
in that and since I brought up my first
gripe which again is more an issue of
Thai and again that's not to say that it
was actually okay at the time you know
with that sort of race portrayal but it
was also of the time so you know that
there's there's only I can recognize
that it's a problem and I'm not saying
that it was okay but it also was not
atypical it was not above and beyond
what was kind of going on in
entertainment all over the place for the
era what I think is actually a bit more
of a structural fundamental this doesn't
really work element of the story are the
cyber mats now they get introduced here
and they're sort of these little
caterpillar looking metal things and
there's two problems with them the first
is it's very unclear what it is that
they do and what about them is actually
dangerous they're clearly intended to be
dangerous because you know the Cybermen
are like the cyber mats will attack but
exactly what they do is is never really
established very clearly so the threat
is very vague and nebulous and doesn't
help that when they're defeated they're
kind of defeated very easily and
repeatedly like I think the only one
that works at all is the very first one
which is actually smaller than most of
the ones we see because they use trick
photography to have it you have it
zipping around which was a little like
okay I'm not sure what it does but that
thing's quick the problem is they think
they got really enamored that they
managed to get some remote control ones
going so the bigger ones are so slow
they move so slowly and again it's
really unclear what it is they do and
they are repeatedly you know just
grabbed and thrown aside knocked off
people they don't seem to really do much
damage and it's made worse that there's
this loud
and initially cut it's so loud that it
makes it really irritating that it takes
the character so long to notice that
they're around on a couple of occasions
and at first I'm like well maybe that's
like part of the soundtrack and like
it's just a signal to the audience that
they're around except that I could tell
it got quieter at certain points so this
this was meant to be the noise they make
because it's getting quieter depending
if they were further away like around a
corner or something but the characters
in the show still weren't noticing it
and yeah they just and and they also
feel like they artificially lengthen the
episodes by use of the cyber mats like
initially when the Cybermen bring out
the bigger ones they set them down and
nothing happens and they're like the
cyber mats need to be rich or whatever
it is they say so like you spend like a
solid minute setting them down and
having them like twitch around and
literally do nothing
just so that you could pick them up
again and send them that was like why
why did you did like there's some weird
extended bits of this I don't know if
they were just trying to pad things out
or if they actually thought that it was
building suspense and fee around these
things but it didn't and it doesn't help
that they kind of look a little adorable
so I think even at the time you even
taking into account the era the
production value and everything else I
just don't think the cyber mats work
just flat out but now that I've done my
complaints let me come back to why this
is one of my favorite episodes and it
really has to do with the second doctor
himself so many of my favorite second
doctor moments are in this episode I can
cite you basically three specifically
that are among some of my favorite
Doctor Who moments at all there's
actually the thing that I kind of did in
my intro bit he has a he has a beat with
Victoria that is so sweet and so
touching because she's kind of she's
still dealing with the fact that her
father's dead
and you know she says I'm I'm sure you
don't even remember your family he has
this moment what I do if I want to and
that's the thing I have to want to
remember them and I can bring them in
front of my eyes but otherwise they're
just asleep in the back of my
head it's just this sweet slightly
melancholy moment it doesn't hammer the
melancholy like Saints character version
like Eccleston would later on but it's
just this touch of it this oh it's a
sweet old man so I love that that scene
that's a great one he's got a bit with
klieg later on he plays klieg quite a
bit over the course of this story and
one of the you know he sort of
encourages him into this big villain
monologue which Clete doesn't that when
then the doctor goes so you are mad
okay good I just wanted to be sure and
the other one that I loved and this like
maybe this makes the cybermat worth
worth it cuz I love this so much the
doctor basically sets up this sort of
trap where he like sends out an electric
impulse and and then fries the the cyber
mats that are coming after them he said
well I I've completely shorted out their
little metal mines you might even say
they've had a complete mental breakdown
and Jamie's next one goes oh I'm sorry I
love the body of that moment that he
makes this terrible pun and Jamie's
immediate like oh no it's I just I love
that I love that moment so much it is it
and again it's the epitome of that
relationship between the two of them
that again I love I love second doctor
and Jamie other than that the this this
episodes also paced really well it's a
four-part er and despite the slight bit
of padding that it feels like was put in
there with cyber mats it is actually
paced really well from episode to
episode to episode we get our first look
at a Cyberman of sorts at the end of the
first episode we've got you know the
Cybermen coming out of their hibernation
later on and that it all builds really
well it's spread out well across the
four episodes in terms of the escalation
of things and how things pan out you
know it's it's just and I could imagine
where some people might complain that
this archaeological team is frankly kind
of stupid like they there's some of the
members who just like oh well let's
please switching is over here yeah it's
one of the Americans go figure and
ultimately gets him killed but that's
kind of the point
like these people aren't prepared this
is not the team that should be here and
there and they are underprepared for the
situation that they're in
and I feel like it feeds into that well
enough that normally that would annoy me
but I'm like well yeah it's kind of
making a point with it but despite the
two major issues and and again your
mileage may vary on how much you're able
to overlook those things the the race
issues with with those three characters
and then cyber mats you know how easily
it is to overlook those that's gonna
vary from person to person and if they
drag the episode of this story down more
for you than they do for me I get it but
I still love this episode I still love
this story so so much because the it for
the time it looks right the music's
really good too they have this really
unsettling music when the when the
Cybermen are around that works quite
effectively and every now and then like
I'll have commenters mentioned you know
the music's in some of these episodes go
on the music was great and nine times
out of ten with the classic episodes
they'll be like really I didn't even
notice
I noticed it here the music for the
Cybermen terrific so I I really enjoyed
and like I said to date my favorite
second doctor story as I get caught up
maybe I'll find another one but for
right now this is it for me absolutely
adore it despite its flaws so those are
my thoughts on tombs of the Cybermen
what do you think about it if you've
seen it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's also a whole bunch
of stuff to do because there's buttons
in there's links including one to my
patreon so check them out if you want
but if you don't feel like it you know
what don't sweat it folks cuz you're the
counselor and I only run the meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]